[Music]
welcome back to careful boys no this is
a hot seat well isn't hot seat a segment
of careful buildings this is how hot
seat gets open dude everyone knows how
hot he gets over here
open
welcome to hot seat the show with the
hottest scene the hottest questions here
is our hot seat guest today steve green
thank you who's usually a host
so hashi is the show where we like to
try to you know we get some of the hot
seating
the heat all right
and to start off the cold questions
bart hid it you used to be a san diego
man correct yes so out of
all the beaches
are you more of a white sand kind of guy
or a black sand i'm white saying kind of
yeah good
good good good starter question is the
correct answer you know why why because
it's [ __ ] beautiful
i love the texture as well have you ever
been on a white sand beach and then you
got like the turquoise ocean
and you're like the bahamas or some [ __ ]
yeah
what's your favorite beach in the world
any corona commercial beach um
100
[Laughter]
i'm chasing the [ __ ] dream honestly
but yeah so far i would say bahamas are
you a tropical dude or more like a
forest dude tropical dude is that your
favorite climate do i look like a forest
dude do you kinda you've known me for a
long time am i fortunate you look more
like a indoor dude thank you that's true
so i'm a tropical guy an indoor tropical
guy no i'm a resort guy bro i'm a
[ __ ] white trash resort person my
thai is kind of guy
oh i've been to you know where have i
been to bali you say yeah oh yeah i've
experienced bali the resort [ __ ] i
don't want to go to [ __ ]
there was like oh yeah i don't know
because i want to go with the locals
like if casey was here to be like i just
don't go to like the local spots and i'm
like
[ __ ] whatever
[Laughter]
[ __ ] take me to the [ __ ] five-star
resort and i'm never leaving take me to
where they speak english and indonesia
[ __ ] yeah
can i get a hamburger here how did you
get
so into crypto so into crypto
uh you know uh
okay a couple years ago my mom was well
i got into crypto first in 2013 i was
buying bitcoin right how did you even
like get into that and how did you
believe in it buddy of mine
he's a big time stoner and he's like
dude let's [ __ ] buy crypto and i was
like what the [ __ ] is that he's like
let's buy nobody's called a crypto he
said let's call let's buy bitcoin dude
is he a bitcoin millionaire now no okay
he didn't go ham oh yeah he bought he
bought once and then he sold it like
when it doubled or whatever and then he
was like [ __ ] yeah
which makes sense at the time yeah at
the time yeah yeah but yeah it was like
we were buying in a thousand bucks yeah
so then it went to 2000 and he's like
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] and i'll see you
later yeah you know how much bitcoin he
had he had one we both bought one
together oh i thought he had like 300 of
them or something
we both bought one i bought 1.2 or
whatever the [ __ ] i bought yeah and then
it immediately went down it went like
like i'm telling you i bought the exact
top and it went down like the next
[ __ ] day and it was and then it went
to 125 each and i was like damn we got
[ __ ] red
but i had done enough reading on it by
that point um because i just i just got
into it nice i bought it first and i
started reading about it after
and then i was like oh i actually think
that this is dope i think that there's a
use for all this [ __ ] like can i read
the satoshi white paper so then i was
like oh [ __ ] this is like a movement so
i held it i never sold it and you're
doing this during like when you were
really active in youtube and comedy oh
yeah i was doing it it was 2013 so i was
gonna be like trolling like every
[ __ ] week i was nice i was writing at
maker studios like every day so yeah i
was all the way in so i didn't really
have time to
really research crypto yet um and then
when my channel got demonetized i was
like what the [ __ ] am i going to do bro
when was that was like 2015.
that's well you already with us around
that time right we were making content
here i had uh i think 2016's when i came
in this
room maybe it was late 2015 because i i
think i remember when you were like [ __ ]
they won't get my channel back and then
you kept i kept going back and forth
with them like pushing back was there a
specific video that got your channel
demonetized they said there's like 62 of
them that got my channel
yeah
does it mean like your channel you can
post but you can't get ads on it if i
want to have my channel back and
monetize it again i have to to remove
60-something videos and i've refused you
access you can access it something yeah
i can access it yeah i have control on
my channel okay but then like they they
just won't put any ads on it exactly
were you spreading misinformation about
covet back in 2015 i was yeah i was
exactly yeah
i was creating material that um they
found that people could jerk off to
that's what they said oh the sex and
public one not just my face dude oh it's
too sexy it's your thumbnail
at your peak when you were monetizing
off your youtube videos how much you
were making i was doing like five
thousand a month or something like that
at the peak yeah at the beginning you
were getting millions of views okay yeah
but bro uh my stuff was very not
you know that's not the way that money
is right and
millions of views like that the amount
that i got was split with maker right so
like yeah my channel was probably
getting like 15 20 000 but like after my
production costs and stuff and when i
was oh i see i see that's what i took
okay yeah so that's why i i think my
channel is doing like 20 000. that makes
sense yeah damn yeah that's cool that
was your take home but i put it all back
into the show like all the time i kept
putting it all back into the show so
what were you living on
just like scraps and then you put the
money right back in that stuff but i was
also hired as a writer at maker at the
time and i was that's where i met timmy
and everybody and oh yeah we were all
doing videos together back then too so i
would write for like a lot of their
talent that were in their building a lot
of them i got the air quotes but then i
would write um for a lot of people that
i liked as well so it was really cool um
so but you know it's a skill it's a
skill to write for somebody else's voice
in their voice and to be able to do that
so that was hard at first because like
you know when you're when you're coming
up in the comedy scene you're like
really stuck on your like your vibe and
like you know it's like oh my way and
all this [ __ ] but like you suck as a
writer if you can't write to somebody
else's voice in my opinion so so were
you once a pretentious artist oh [ __ ]
yeah dude i was way full of my i was way
full of [ __ ] what do you think it is
happens to a lot of people when they
first get into the entertainment world
where they have this idea that they're
so unique and different and better than
everybody else when they just started i
think it's i think
i think that there's a level of
confidence that you have to have and
like obviously vanity that you have to
have to even do this [ __ ] at all like to
go like i'm gonna record myself and then
people need to see this [ __ ]
you're already like full of yourself in
a way right yeah so but unnecessary for
yourself fully you're full yourself um
but but to get to the point where um
you kind of need some barbs up if you're
gonna ever make something and like walk
into a room with other people who have
opinions too you have to be able to
defend your
[ __ ] so sometimes i think people just do
it extra hard yeah and they like really
layer those walls thick and i think it's
a huge mistake what broke you out of
that to become more like
easy to work with and then you play the
game and then you you kind of i think
that's what got you into you know making
movies and doing all this other stuff i
think that it was meeting cool people
because at first i was really
unimpressed with the people i was
meeting in on the tubes like who oh [ __ ]
i mean it's hard to know that's an
anthony question yeah yeah first and
last night i thought you were going to
say it who did you meet and we'll leave
it to ourselves like we think i met
everybody
the skin color that it matches the most
uh it's because we all have such
fluctuating skin color here because i
think we could tell which one is the one
or not yeah but it was really i mean it
was really both right i think i didn't
like myself as much too and so there's a
lot of that going on at the same time
where you're like you're like i see you
you see yourself in other people and
you're like i [ __ ] hate that guy but
do i hate myself
yeah i think i was doing a lot of that
you really do like what you really do
when you look back yeah it helps when
you look back because you really do see
how full of [ __ ] you were and then how
full of [ __ ] they were yeah and then
like i see how stubborn i was at the
same time like i would always be like
how cringe yeah it just happens because
we all been there like in the creative
field you think you're just [ __ ] way
better than the world you're so [ __ ]
cool you have that you have that initial
confidence that's really stupid and and
it's weird too cause like i remember at
the time thinking like
well i you know i wish i could meet
cooler people and [ __ ] and like
because everyone on the tubes was really
into themselves and i didn't like that i
didn't like like remember at the time we
had these little cameras and red button
in the middle a vertical one yeah and
everyone's vlogging and i i thought i
was better than vlogging and [ __ ] and
yeah you just you just have to grow up a
little bit i think and then was uh who
were some of the easiest people to write
for and who were some of the hardest
timmy d because he doesn't even read his
email so
i'll just leave that screen you'll
[ __ ] write whatever you want he's
down to do whatever he's down he'll just
pick up the script he's probably one of
the coolest dudes on youtube though
where you just like oh this guy is just
he's enjoying life and he just wants to
play some of his skits that we've been
in he's are you down yeah cool and he
had the whole maker production team
there and this fool's writing in the
living room like on the day of the he's
like i don't even have the idea i just
knew we should do something i remember
doing
i mean anything i did with him was
really fun it was fun every time and
they had a great vibe on set which was
not always the case like so there's some
people who really are full of themselves
like big time
um
so you always got on with timmy i love
castle and castle is always cool dude
um
shay carl is a super good dude
you know
loves hot women
oh good dude really good dude i still
talk to shae sometimes he's a good guy
um
but yeah i mean all those guys like
especially in maker like the core people
who like founded the place they were
always really cool every one of them was
really cool today's video is brought to
you by upstart
nothing is more discouraging than paying
toward your credit card but barely
making a dent in your debt that's why
upstart is here to help you pay off your
debt quickly so you can get ahead
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether you're paying off credit
cards or consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over
half a million people have used upstart
to get one fixed monthly payment upstart
knows you're more than just your credit
score and is expanding access to
affordable credit unlike other lenders
upstart uses your income and current
employment to help you find a smarter
rate for your loan with a five minute
rate check you can see your rate up
front for loans of 1 000 to up to 50 000
and receive your funds as fast as one
business day after being accepted for
your loan so find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today by
going to upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com off
the record and don't forget to use the
url so they know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined by your
credit your income and other certain
information that you put on your
application make sure you go to
upstart.com
off the record
what was like the hardest
or toughest moment in your youtube
career so there was a video i did call
it was like one of my bang bus prank
videos right and and there was a guy who
um so what we used to do was we would
have people sign a release like before
they get in the bus so like it's like
hey you're about to shoot porn with
these chicks we need to sign this
release
and so this one guy he thought he was
gonna get the [ __ ] like these two porn
stars
and
he signs his release and then we get him
in the van and we do the whole bit and
like these two guys get in and he's like
[ __ ] mortified and [ __ ] and then
afterwards um
he leaves right everything's cool he
leaves he's like i got you know [ __ ] i
didn't know
and then um i'm going with the porn
stars to go get other guys to the van
and my producer at the time the guy
comes back
and he asks for his release back and my
producer time hands it to him oh no and
so because he did that when we put the
video out we're like you know what we'll
we'll we can flog his face out we had to
talk to the maker lawyers and [ __ ] and
like okay if you fog his face out
you'll be fine because nobody can
recognize him [ __ ] well he he called my
producer like after it comes out and
like it gets a million views in 24 hours
like those always did
and then i had to they're like they're
like steve needs to take this video down
because the guy just called and like we
don't want to have any [ __ ] like
disney doesn't want to deal with
anything right
and i was like [ __ ] um and it's funny
too because people think i faked this
[ __ ]
um but dude this that was what sucked
about it is that like because we really
did it with real people
this situation sucked and then maker was
like um either you take it down we're
gonna take it down and i and i was like
how are you gonna do that just change my
[ __ ] password i'm on the phone with
you [ __ ] what are you gonna do and then
um he's like we're on the back and
and then uh basically make her legal
like after like three days
they were they got back to me and
they're like hey look we're just gonna
disassociate our relationship with you
if you don't take the video down and i
was like
yeah it was like that so then i was like
and like no production no anything like
you're you'll be done if you don't take
the video down i was like [ __ ]
so i took how many views it had been oh
it was at three million already yeah and
it was it was getting posted all over
the place like especially in the first
like hour or whatever it was already
getting posted all over the place so i
was like this is going to be great right
and then you know that call comes and
then that sort so that sucked only
because
like man did we work hard i know it
sounds like like um stupid
to anybody who works hard but but we
worked hard to to make the video get the
right people and like to meet the person
and to like suss them out and know that
he'll take himself seriously enough
where he'll it'll be funny in the van
and he won't try to like juggle
somebody's bowls and like
i'm a funny guy you know you don't want
that guy in there you want the guy who
takes himself too seriously in there you
know he thought he was gonna get two
girls he thought he was gonna [ __ ] these
two porn stars yeah and he was super
like i don't know through his buddies
and [ __ ] he's like oh i don't know and
that's what i know such a great market
it was perfect it was perfect and it was
a great video too
is that still findable like is it out
there and it's
prank three i'm sure somebody has uh
re-uploaded it yeah i would have pimped
slapped the [ __ ] out of your producer
and i would have been like you call his
ass back right now and say i'm sorry
we're gonna get you two girls i went in
on him hard i mean i never i've never
yelled at anybody at that whole company
i didn't give it to him that's a pretty
big oopsie um crazy i don't know i don't
know he's a nice guy you guys know bryce
oh bryce he's cool he's a nice guy yeah
he's so
i was just furious because i
i had no other options like that was it
because if we didn't have the release we
were [ __ ] so i was like damn i have to
take this what was the best moment of
your like youtube crew i really enjoyed
doing the
topless trolling one
because that was the point that i wanted
to make for a long time like where these
girls were doing the free the nipple
campaign
and i got to go to the protest and then
like the whole time i was just staring
at their tits how did you find out that
that's what they were going to do like
did you they used so like in venice
beach they post like uh a month in
advance of whatever have you seen this
video it's hilarious oh my god he's like
ty's like he's like tell me about your
movement and then she's like talk oh
it's about feminism whatever and he's
like oh yeah
[Laughter]
okay sorry what'd you say that again
that's the point i always wanted to make
to people because i believe in free
nipple go for it but also that's what's
going to happen yeah that's uh that's
all there's trade-offs yeah there's a
trade-off that's it there's a trade-off
i like that one i like doing um
i had this one for chick-fil-a that i
liked a lot that um
because you know when you're trolling
then you have to sometimes take an angle
and so i did this one where
i had i had this contract that i was i
was i said i was willing to allow gay
people because of the time chick-fil-a
was like going down for a bunch of gay
stuff yeah like anti-gay stuff yeah and
i was like hey look
um i want to talk to gay people gay
community homosexual people
um i have a contract right here
we're willing to give straights we're
willing to give you guys straight gay
marriage we're down
but you have to promise that it's not
going to go in like from there and like
you're going to start marrying a bunch
of table furniture or some [ __ ]
and you're a chick-fil-a man yeah and i
was like
i was just there like at the interview
and i was like we're trying to we're
trying to like we're trying to i'm
trying to as a straight guy open up our
movement to you guys like you know let's
have a conversation and like let's let's
you know meet the table
and sign a treaty but you guys got to
promise not to start marrying a bunch of
[ __ ] dinette furniture or whatever
the hell
like we don't know because we because if
you if you're starting here we don't
know what the hell is going to happen
next you know and
that was the narrative at that time
yeah that's the slippery slope argument
that they always use yeah yeah what's
next an animal let me tell you something
i never
would um my favorite thing about
trolling all the time was i like that i
got to bring my weird thing to their
environment
and then when i just left and they got
to think was that even [ __ ] real what
just happened
i loved that part of it i didn't i
didn't like the reveal as much that
stuff i always didn't like that much
but this one guy is one really nice gay
guy
he was so upset that i thought that he
was gonna start marrying dogs and stuff
which is their argument that's yeah yeah
that's right that's the thing it's an
existing theory that was the existing
fear at the time so
so i kind of was so and i was so
troubled that he was gonna maybe start
marrying like poodles or whatever
that that's so troubled he personally
troubled he was like
shaken
by the by that interaction like
afterward he's just so [ __ ] hyped up
and [ __ ] and like [ __ ] just like
angry and and i was like hey man hey man
i'm on the same team but i'm the same
team i'm free movement this is just i'm
pointing out what the other side is
saying and he was just like
oh my god
he was so relieved he was so relieved
his stereotype was playing and he
thought that you were really one of them
really one of them and i think that he
thought he's like how are we ever going
to get through
this is what we're up against how the
[ __ ] is this ever gonna work out that's
the disbelief yeah he's like we'll have
to live on a different island or
something
he was just happy that you weren't the
adversary yeah yeah yeah yeah but that's
pretty rare of you to like reveal like
that yeah i didn't never really do that
but but yeah a couple times i i would
because yeah did you do that for
westboro baptists you never revealed not
no i just pissed those guys off in fact
steve the main guy at westboro i didn't
know he was like the main guy but he was
there and so i was like i was like uh
i was like hey man like
how i got him to do the interview
because i was wearing american fly tag
tagging [ __ ] american fly uh american
flag um
and i was i was like hey man um
you know nobody ever actually just has
has a conversation with you guys tries
to understand your point of view that's
all i want to do
and he's like okay all right whatever
you know as long as you're not going to
do some [ __ ] i was like no no he's like
no your microphone is not going to
squirt anything on me are you and i'm
like no no
you probably like that [ __ ] you know but
but um so then so then uh i was like
okay cool tell me about like what is
what is in the bible that makes you
believe this and he's like well in
leviticus 10 12 it says man that shall
not lay with another man
what do you think about that and i was
like
uh i think he just wanted them to do it
standing up
[Laughter]
this guy was just like
like you know he knew it like he he like
he was almost like see that's why i
don't talk to people
[Laughter]
you played it so cool forever yeah yeah
yeah he's like i swore i would never
[ __ ] do this that's why i don't do
[ __ ] interviews
like it was like that so that was a fun
one have you ever been close to like
getting in a fight with somebody yeah
there was a couple times i mean there
there's i think i have a decent way of
de-escalating a situation where i just
seem like i'll probably be
a bad idea to fight them not because of
intimidating or threatening but because
i'll just do something crazy out of
nowhere i'll just say something [ __ ]
weird out of nowhere but there's like
what and like it short circuits their
head and they're like oh okay
i'm gonna turn it i'm gonna turn it up
for the last part all right all right so
you're obviously hella passionate when
you talk about this it's like man it
seems like these were the the some of
the best times of your life how did that
feel when it all [ __ ] got taken from
you it hurt man it hurt i'd tell you it
took probably two years for me to get
over it like like i don't think i'm
still completely over it because i still
i love doing all that stuff but it just
doesn't make sense to do it now because
of
um the culture has changed well well
it's really just a i think i think it'd
be great to do it now if anything
because of how seriously everyone takes
themselves because the culture changed
yeah but yeah but and you know i i can't
say i saw it coming like this like the
way everyone takes themselves so
seriously now i was like [ __ ] wild
but that was always what my thing was
it's like don't take yourself too
[ __ ] seriously and you know anytime i
catch myself because we all do it we're
all human beings anytime i catch myself
take myself too seriously i'm always
like wait a minute like that's not what
we want to be so it's something you
gotta remind yourself constantly but
yeah i definitely was i would say
depressed for like a good two years
afterwards thankfully i found this place
this place really saved me in that time
because
i didn't feel like i had anywhere to go
to like to be myself
and that's why i love this [ __ ] run
so i love you guys cool man yeah love
you
if you had to [ __ ] a dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you